I'll Drive actually I want to try
something saw in the comic book
[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 5 video there were
so many Easter eggs mostly introducing
the rag dog character but there was also
a new crossover trailer in a reference
to what they're doing with Caitlyn's
father there's a new brand of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment about the episode on the video
so just careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet
starting with number 10 there's a jewel
heist Norah tries to help out but
because she's been ducking Barry and
iris she hasn't had the training that
she needs
so she totally Boches it almost kills an
elderly couple and has that look on her
face like she has after every time she'd
herbs like um jeez I'm sorry dad oh this
sucks
it was actually an easter egg on one of
the trucks as they were driving around
usually street names wind up being
Easter eggs for either people that are
crew members or for a comic book names
the name on the truck here Shapira is
actually the name of one of the crew
members 9 caitlin learns that her father
had a working relationship with martin
stein in the past which is actually
really cool tied to legends of tomorrow
even though we don't really know what
martin stein is up to right now because
he hasn't been on that show for a while
they also use Caitlin's storyline to
tell the story of how Cisco will
basically have to stop being vibe for
most of the rest of the season while his
hands heal or until they can find a way
to fix him I think he'll get his powers
back eventually like the only person
that you really don't want to be without
their powers for an extended period of
time is Barry because the TV show is
called the flash but I think this is
actually the first time we've seen a
close-up of Caitlin's father it's in a
flashback but they keep referring to all
the equations obviously that's all setup
that they pay off by the end of the
episode when we got that teaser for his
introduction next week so they've been
doing this thing the past couple of
episodes where you see her father has
been working on a lot of equations and
mystery science that we don't really
know I'm guessing it has something to do
with him becoming the Icicle character
and Caitlin becoming killer frost but
number 8 we finally get to meet ragdoll
for the first time crawling out of that
box like the creepy clown that he is so
if you're not a big comic book reader
they did change the way his powers work
in the way he got his powers in the
comics ragdoll is not a metahuman he
actually just has surgery to make
himself triple-jointed
I thought they did a good job with the
special effects like you can do most of
this practical the actor underneath the
costume is actually a contortionist in
real life so he
a lot of this practically but when he's
crawling through vents or weenies
smashing his hands obviously that has to
be CG but when he does that creepy move
turning his head around like an owl
that's actually practical that's the
actor just turning his head around that
far he becomes a member of the secret
six in the comics I don't know what
their plans are for the future of this
character on the TV show but anybody
that they introduced that doesn't die is
always fair game to come back seven
cecile agrees to tell Norah stories
about Barry that didn't make it into the
flash Museum the funny thing about this
when she says Barry went into the past
and fought golden Giants caulk Rodin's
that's a real flash comic book it was
flash number one 20 it was an adventure
that he had with Kid Flash so this is
way back during the Silver Age it's as
ridiculous as it sounds I don't know why
they would keep that out of the flash
museum maybe they just don't want to
blow people's minds too much like wait a
minute there were golden giants living
in the past what the hell they name drop
Supergirl there's a couple references to
things that they're gonna pay off during
the crossover leg when Barry is sitting
here on the couch you see the picture of
him and iris that they took a long time
ago but in the trailer video that I just
posted it's Oliver in the picture so
they're just setting up a lot of things
for the crossover that they'll pay off
like there was a line of dialogue where
Barry said try to be the person you are
right now don't worry about here you're
gonna become but the funny thing about
that is that he's going to become Green
Arrow in a couple weeks six we get
ragdolls true origin stories so on the
TV show it was his mother that never
approved of him and cast him out she's
this billionaire industrialist that
seems like she's super smart because she
figures out immediately what Barry and
iris are there for the writers do things
like that just to let you know that
characters are extremely intelligent
like I know what the hell is going on
here just ask me your stupid questions
and then get the hell out of my party
the story on the TV show is is that she
gave him everything growing up but he
didn't live up to her expectations so
she cut him off
so cold as hell colder than killer frost
that is one mean mom right there but it
just meant to be a metaphor for irises
relationship with Nora so it seems like
most of that drama is gonna be over by
next week like the way they ended the
episode with Nora being all excited
about iris but I do like the idea that
ragdoll got his powers when he was
crushed during the Enlightenment by the
dark matter satellite like it literally
flattened him like we see him flatten
himself
the other minor comic-book changed that
they made is is that in the comics he's
Peter Merkel jr. it's his father who was
the earlier version of ragdoll that he
took the mantle from who never approved
of him during the Silver Age Peter
Merkel senior his father was the
original version of rag doll and the
whole thing about his character is is
that the thinker brainwashed him to
commit crimes based on dolls so the kind
of remix seeing aspects of the original
origin story five Cisco passes the freak
out when they're investigating Caitlin's
father's burnt out loud they also find
out that he faked the arson so he's been
hiding out this whole time just throwing
people off the trail but this is more
about Cisco than it is about Caitlin
even though it is really cool to get
this backstory on icicle Kaelin explains
the reason for Cisco having seizures is
that they're still metal from cicadas
dagger embedded in his hands and he'll
just seize up every time he tries to use
his powers again so eventually once they
find a way to get the metal out then
he'll be able to heal his hands fully
and be able to fly up again it'll
probably be sometime in the back half of
the season but it's a great scene like
they have this really emotional moment
about how Cisco is worried he won't be
able to contribute it's the same thing
for all the other members of team flash
when they lose their powers or the
people that do not have powers to begin
with so they kind of paid that off with
the iris West storyline at the end of
the episode when she jumps out of the
building we're on the way to that don't
worry
number four spider-man elongated man
this is actually really funny they
always find ways to do comic book II
stuff in a really silly way with his
character I saw this in a comic book
once I want to try something he's
actually grabbing the buildings with his
hands so technically instead of web
slinging it's more like arm slinging but
it's just one in a long line of Marvel
references that they include in episodes
pretty good moment but number three like
I said pushing Barry off the building
and iris jumping after him this is a lot
like the moment that iris had when she
jumped out of the building while she was
on a case just waiting for Barry to
catch her like Barry tells her you trust
me right and she's like oh okay I'll
jump out of this building just assuming
that he would be there in time and at
the time it was a really badass stunt
and we haven't had that many iris badass
stunts since then so this is just a
really solid moment from the episode
these are the really good action scenes
that you give her character because it
involves the team working together like
you need Barry's power
working in concert with Iris literally
taking a leap of faith and they use it
to wrap up that Nora drama storyline so
thankfully they're moving past that it
was getting kind of tired of them
sniping at each other
cisco gives ragdoll his comic-book name
in number to team Caitlyn which I'm just
gonna call collectively because they're
all built around Caitlyn's storyline
finds out where her father is her mother
apparently has all these military
contracts so there are black sites all
over the place doing crazy dark research
her father seems like he's been hiding
out at one of these places ever since he
faked his death so cisco hacks the four
satellites that the thinker left in
orbit gives them a bunch of Easter Egg
names there's how Robbie data and
Colossus so Hal is Hal for Hal 9000 from
2001 Space Odyssey
Robbie is named for Robbie the robot
from that classic Forbidden Planet movie
data is data from Star Trek obviously in
the Colossus reference maybe for a giant
mech or maybe Colossus from x-men but
that doesn't really fit with his scheme
of naming things after robots you guys
can let me know what you think he was
referencing by naming that last one
Colossus but obviously number one WTF is
that teaser for the Icicle episodes they
go they fight him he has crazy-looking
frost powers way more powerful than
Caitlin's and it seems like they're
setting him up to be sort of a backdoor
villain so anytime someone seems like
they're trying to do something good I
wanted to quarantine myself but then
things slowly start to go off the rails
and don't quite add up like something is
kind of fishy here what's going on and
it seems like they want to drive a wedge
between Caitlin and team flash like he's
my only family left and obviously team
flashes her family so she has to choose
between her biological family in the
family of her friends it makes for a
really good TV
and if you're a big fan of Young Justice
they used the Icicle character quite a
lot so it'll be interesting to see what
they do with him because he's a huge
character so I think that they're gonna
try and keep him around for a while
hopefully he'll be here after the
mid-season finale if you didn't see it
they also dropped another trailer for
the crossover during the episode and it
was just the Barry version of the Oliver
trailer that I just did a video for so
you have Barry waking up in the middle
of a fight with Diggle not knowing that
he's the green arrow so the flash has
become the green arrow so I'll do a
video for that tomorrow when I do
trailer video for the next episode no
worries on AIM a new giveaway winner
when I post that video click here for
that crossover trailer and click here
for my Ryan Reynolds detective Pikachu
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome see you guys
tonight
[Music]